Pippa let me let me ask you when Sam
you've done now four or five movies
together what's yeah so we've we've had
a company together for 20 years now
obviously I was a child when we started
um but we actually grew up together so
what's very odd about this film is that
uh we lived through this period together
as as children and and lived through his
mum kind of disintegrating which is
obviously at the heart of the story
Olivia's character is is really based on
his mum and her mental health struggles
so it's a it's been a very odd process
watching this come to life on screen
was it very different because it was so
personal for Sam yes and it's the first
um script he's written completely on his
own when we did 1917 Christy Wilson
Cairns uh and he worked together on that
script but this was something that kind
of had been percolating away and then
rather alarmingly for any producers in
the audience who work with directors
your director says actually I've written
something of my own and you think oh no
that could be really terrible but um but
actually it was uh it was
extraordinarily good as even as a first
draft and and the finished film is
probably
95 that first draft so he just it just
kind of came out fully formed and Olivia
he called you one day and said I've
written you have no choice but to do
this part I wrote it for you without you
asking but that's a huge compliment yeah
yes it's so big compliment no bit scary
right
um I heard that he wanted to have a zoom
meeting with me
um Sam Mendes wants to zoom you and it
was in my kitchen but he talked nothing
about the film I didn't know what it was
he just said I've been writing something
and thinking of you and I went okay
great yes
um and then I realized I probably
shouldn't have said yes until I'd read
it but um luckily when the script came
through I was really excited and um it
was a part I'd never played before and
um with uh and it was made me nervous
which is always quite a nice feeling
weirdly
um so actually it turned out all right
and what what was it that made you
nervous I mean number one you're on the
set with the director and you're playing
someone inspired by his mom that in
itself is kind of nerve-wracking but
there were there were that plus what
other elements um well if anyone who had
witnessed schizophrenia bipolar or or
had you know suffered with those issues
I didn't didn't want I wanted to do it
justice for them I didn't want to let
down Sam and
the the great thing for me was that Sam
had been an observer of this every day
of his life and you know as a single an
only child with a single mum
um he watched every moment of it and he
was worried by a changing eye makeup
could signify a change in you know her
trajectory so I had him to go
so when when you stop lithium and he
could describe everything he could help
me so I had him holding my hands every
step of the way which was brilliant
and how early did did Trent and Atticus
did you start talking to Sam about this
you you start from what my from what I
understand you were working on the score
well before you actually saw any film
well like uh Olivia mentioned we had a
zoom as well and uh I think the first
one was probably
let's my memory is bad but let's say it
was six months before or four months
before
before the cameras yeah before the
camera was picked up and then we got
into this thing of we'd Zoom for a
couple of hours every two weeks or so
and then the last couple of months we
we've got to a point where you know he
knew where he was going to shoot and the
script was in a place and he'd shared
enough with us that we were able to kind
of
do some kind of improvisations around
the base and find the kind of
world you know like World building in
terms of the Sonic world that this
school might sit in and feel appropriate
to tell the emotional story and oh sorry
I was just going to say one of the
things that was most extraordinary was
because these guys had as they say had
laid down quite a lot of music before we
started shooting so when we started
shooting Sam was listening to their
music as we shot which I'd never
experienced before and he he hadn't
either and he found it extraordinarily
helpful because it kind of shaped the
music it shaped the way he shot it
um which is just you know really unusual
and Olivia let's I wanted to get into
the said design a little bit and the I
know Pippa you'll have a lot to say
about creating the Empire Cinema out of
an existing structure there but I wanted
to talk to you about Hillary's apartment
because so many there are so many I just
saw it for the second time and there are
so many details which she scribbled on
the wall and things like that and I just
wondered what elements were there that
helped you build the character and how
much of it was inspired on why you were
building yourself
um so during rehearsal Sam had told us
um
well you know when you see all the food
jars upside down and everything's
bleeding down he won during one sort of
uh episode of his mum's he went to bed
he could hear it all happening and he
came downstairs and all of the food jars
were open and upside down and when he
walked on walked onto the set first he
said may I and they went yeah yeah for
sure and he he did it and rearranged it
and he did the painting of the writing
on the wall as he remembered it and
um
and there she was a very intelligent
woman and
um when she was on the app sort of so
powerful and so uh lucid and amazing and
all the books you could you know that
she had were there and
um he took them all off the bookshelf
and piled them on the floor as they as
he remembered them
um so for me going in it was I could
have a look around and open everything
and look at everything and I'd already
heard about it from our rehearsals and
it was really moving that and he was
very moved by it all that it was as he
remembered
um and actually the kitchen table
this is a complete non-sequitary I'm so
sorry but um I like to take a little
something from each job do you yeah I
ask I do ask and um I bought the kitchen
table to have yeah which is maybe a bit
weird but uh
Olivia can you talk a little bit about
your working relationship with Michael
and I know you were super excited about
doing sex scenes for one thing
um Michael's very sorry he's not here by
the way
um yes no I I begged Sam to take out all
the sex scenes because I find them
incredibly embarrassing Michael was much
more mature than me and uh we just got
on so well he's so he's like Tigger he's
so happy he so wants to learn everything
he's loving the way everybody works he
loves learning from everybody and he
said no we're going to be fine we've got
each other we'll be fine but we had
eater O'Brien who was a intimacy
coordinator who was a total Game Changer
and she actually we were at drama school
together so um she knows me well and
knows that I'm incredibly embarrassed by
everything and she turned it all into a
dance routine and she said um what do
you not want the show and I said
absolutely nothing so there's I was
fully clothed all the time and
everything's sort of the imagination
from there down
um and she would be offset going and one
and two and a hand down the
so she was brilliant she made it fun and
easy and made us comfortable with each
other
um but Michael was just a joy and thank
God he was confident because otherwise
we'd never have got through it
you and you and Michael uh I talked to
you I guess it was yesterday for my
Sirius XM show and I I love this tidbit
that the scene at the beach the when he
falls when he's running naked into the
surf and trips and falls was a mistake
and then Sam kept it he did it perfectly
many times five times and it's a really
long way to the Seas this poor guy is
running everything flapping about
running and then of course they go cut
and he has to run back and we all
politely look the other way
um and the one time he ran and fell and
uh but he carried on but he had sand in
his eyes he was running the rest of the
way with his eyes closed and and we said
Sam's going to keep that take that's the
one he's going to use and sure enough he
did and Trent in Atticus what was what
was the the piece of music we're seeing
that you discussed the most but whether
it was contentious or just hard to get
right or that everybody had differing
opinions on it what was the most
difficult one to uh make a final
decision on
the opening scene was
um
tough to get right
when she's opening up the yeah just
introducing uh
the cinema the feel and that was a bit
tricky
um unquestionably the hardest one to get
which nearly broke us
was uh watching being there in the
cinema
you know because we sit around thinking
wouldn't it be great to get a film where
there's a Runway where we the music can
be featured in a way and then this came
up when we realized there's about three
or four minutes
of watching someone watch a movie you
know and the music has to it's certainly
you're acting does all the hard work but
we need to frame that in a way that that
can
that is worthy of being with that
and
I think we composed 15 fully arranged
different Suites of music for that scene
and
a couple before the final I was
convinced this is the one because our
method is
to um
once we choose
once we make some cerebral decisions
about instruments and there's the
reality of how long it has to be and
what has to happen at what point then
let's just try to get lost in the
emotion and mine the place that
you're where you're in there crying and
feeling
you know and about about the 13th time
and it felt like
I came in on my tears in my eyes I got I
have the I have the raw material for
this
and then the next day when we played it
for Sam
[Laughter]
um
that then it becomes an exercise in
patients and
letting go of ego
and the reality is what's in there I
think is beautiful and is way better and
we wouldn't have gotten there had we not
been pushed there by Sam you know it was
one of the real kind of
learning experiences we had working with
him on this film one of the I missed the
first time I
watched the movie it was on a you know a
small screen but but seeing it on the
big screen tonight but the sound and
everything I noticed that in the in the
scene where uh Hillary is you know
exposing him to his wife and the big
confrontation during the premiere
we hear really faintly the theme from
Chariots of Fire in the background
[Music]
volume of that is so perfect because
it's really faint but you hear it and
it's just great when she's doing that
and I just wanted to know was there is
that why Chariots of Fire was chosen
just so you could play that song under
under the Meltdown
it wasn't our decision but we were
laughing right along with you every time
that comes up it's a perfect perfect
thing for them no I think I think Sam
thought that you know
Chariots of Fire was the perfect film
for for Donald Ellis Colin's character
to be unbelievably proud of premiering
and you know when he he sort of puffs up
and goes on stage to introduce it it
that just felt so perfect and again a
bit a bit like being there obviously it
came out that year and there was a
Premiere just before you know if you
look at the timeline of our script the
actual Premiere was lit about two weeks
before in London so it worked really
well
I want to thank you all for being here I
think we're out of time but
congratulations on the film thank you
The Joy thank you